let's talk about this delta variant man
some people saying we might get some
lockdowns again
god damn it yeah now that's on y'all too
bro i knew it would be i told you
the [ __ ] that comes from india is going
to [ __ ] up everybody most mutated bro
they mutate
that's what we do we got it's the
dirtiest
country i've ever been to i've never
been to china india by far the dirtiest
country i've ever been to whatever the
[ __ ] makes it out of there
yeah we're not ready that [ __ ] is that's
ford tough
do you think that we can lock up again
psychologically no no no no way right
no the numbers will have to be crazy and
i think states will try
but it's going to be like rebellion dog
new york might try
cali might try but i don't think the
citizens are having it
new york is a pretty liberal place
[ __ ] are so happy to not be
wearing masks right now yeah
that's hilarious god dude yeah people
who don't look like
[ __ ] the guy you would think is a big
anti-massacre walking around with no
masks
on the train like they're just not doing
it anymore right we're done mentally
yeah yeah well at what point do they
just say like
now people get coveted and it's okay
because you're vaccinated and you're not
going to
you're more than likely not going to die
so i've got the delta variant
and he uh allegedly got it from his
masseuse and
he's vaccinated so the thing about
the the vaccination is it doesn't stop
you from getting it it's just if you do
get it i think one it's harder to get
and two if you do get it your body can
fight it off
better yeah right but there's always
that percentile that's what people never
really
they don't put that in their mind
they're like 95 percent effective
right and that's an amazing
effectiveness like the efficacy is great
but you could still
get it yes yes there's a five percent
chance you get it and within that five
percent chance
i'm sure there's some people that might
even die
yeah but the majority of people won't
and ideally we get to a point where it's
like yo we can continue on
uh and have a normal society without the
risk of
you know putting hundreds of thousands
of people in the [ __ ] house their
concern is there's some states where
vaccination rates are really low
yeah and in those states things should
get [ __ ] nuts and that's on you
yeah yep like i i i hate to say it but
it's on y'all like
when we got the vaccine i if you got the
vaccine thinking that there were no
risks
you're an idiot yeah we all got
vaccinated or those of us who have got
vaccinated got vaccinated because we
a [ __ ] to get back to normal okay now
if you're not vaccinated you get that
[ __ ] and you die
that is your risk that you took
you are risking your body with covid
some people that have vaccinated are
risking not being able to return to a
normal society
right yeah and we're willing to take
that risk and that's fine
and you gotta live with that but you
can't do pouty face if you go get the
delta variant when you decide not to get
vaccinated
no no no and you can't be pouty face
even i wonder i don't know i you could
probably do patty phase if your state
shuts down even though you don't want to
right because you're like yo let's take
the risk i'm ready to go out here i'm
ready to get the [ __ ]
the only thing that's [ __ ] up is what
i feel bad for are you can't vaccinate
kids
and i'm happy about that because we
don't know what the [ __ ] this thing does
to people
right but i'm also a little bit
concerned because what if the delta
variant starts affecting kids worse
yeah you know the whole time we were
basically like yo
kids have great immune systems they're
gonna be good if they get coveted
everything's fine yeah
but if this one or another variant
affects kids in a more harmful way
now we got to start shooting kids up a
[ __ ] that we really don't know what's
going to happen
yeah 10 years down the line 20 years i
mean i can't take that risk isn't that
historically what most vaccines have
been though
like the [ __ ] smallpox vaccine they
didn't know they didn't have 10 years of
research and know how i was going to go
controlled studies
hey this [ __ ] is ravaging the world
here's a potential vaccine let's
everybody just take it yeah yeah i mean
that's
yeah that's every time you take anything
and there could be i'm sure
mark said it well it's like anti-vaxxers
you don't have to be an anti-vaxxer but
also the people who are
like [ __ ] on anti-vaxxers actually
act like no vaccine could possibly have
any negative side effects whatsoever
that's not true yeah but generally
speaking the risk is worth the reward
yeah i want to go out to dinner you know
it doesn't take much for me to take a
vaccine
yeah like this idea that like oh my god
there's this hill that we cannot
get over or get passed in order for
people to get vaccinated
you just have to take one thing away
from me yeah in order for me to take
vaccines
like if you said you know you can't take
uber's without vaccine i'll take a
vaccine for anything yeah
there's nothing i wouldn't take i take
prep i take the hiv medication right
i take whatever you want so i can take
ubers yeah so if you just remove
one little thing from my life and i get
to see other [ __ ] doing that
[ __ ]
like low-key florida is the only reason
people get vaccinated up north
because if the whole country was shut
down you wouldn't feel like you're
missing something
but when the whole country saw
[ __ ] partying living that good
life in florida and texas
they're like shoot me up yeah i need a
party yo
yeah i want to go to marquis i want to
go out to dinner yeah i want to live my
[ __ ] life again because these puerto
ricans just having an amazing time down
there in florida yeah
so that's on us yep so if this vaccine
does turn out to be bad and we get all
mutated and [ __ ] up can't have kids
my bad science will figure that out we
got time yo
come on sorry we moved down to miami and
had incredible success
real talk but now they can afford good
treatment so that's true you go yeah
we might need something freezing nut or
something say yeah we could have maybe
we should have done that
we should have frozen our nuts girls
should have frozen our eggs yeah
maybe we should have but you never bust
in the freezer one time to save it for
posterity
put that [ __ ] in the ice tray yeah yeah
yeah
that's how you freeze nut for the future
y'all never bust in an ice tray
yeah you never you never played ice tray
roulette yeah i would i didn't refried
it freeze pop
you never busted and one of the water
kills
bro yeah i'm saying bro that's the
roulette yeah
but you just got to do it blind you bust
in one of the trays
one of the cubes that i actually pissed
me off though what does my girlfriend
ice and i'm like oh now you're gonna do
it
once it's frozen you're gonna chew ice
but yeah why don't why does the
government just be honest with us we
could take the honesty
that's the thing that is that's a little
annoying i think that's something
antiquated by the government is like
they think that we can't handle honesty
yeah we can
certain things we don't want them to be
honest about but there's certain things
that we do
you're saying we can handle the truth no
honesty
honestly
like you said like you're arguing with a
girl right now you're like no no i'll be
honest with you i'm not gonna tell you
i'm not gonna tell you
i'm being honest about how untruthful
i'm about to be no no like i guess what
i'm saying is it's just like yo do you
wanna go back outside
hey this is the [ __ ] deal you wanna
go back outside or not yes
well we need seven out of ten y'all to
take this [ __ ] [ __ ] which one of
y'all are going to be the heroes to open
up the whole country and that is some
heroic stuff
we are taking a vaccine that we do not
know what happens
so that the three out of the ten can
also go out
and enjoy [ __ ] life if you're someone
who does not get vaccinated i think we
said this on his podcast i think it was
on a podcast
maybe somewhere it was in the green room
it was in a green room yeah exactly if
you're someone who's not vaccinated and
you see someone who is vaccinated you
thank them
because your [ __ ] ass is able to go out
and enjoy [ __ ] life
because people got vaccinated